qui est pour qui est contre la science
est levée
la séance est levée
bonjour Bruno millièmes je suis député
de la 9e circonscription des Yvelines et
avec mon collègue Gérard le seul nous
avons fait un rapport sur les ZFE les
zones à faible émission mobilité avec
tous les freins à la mise en place de
ces ZFE et toutes les contraintes que ça
suppose pour les habitants pour les
particuliers comme pour les
professionnels et mon boulot maintenant
c'est d'aller en circonscription pour
expliquer ça à nos administrés à nos
concitoyens et leur dire qu'on a des
solutions alternatives et qu'il faut
absolument les mettre en place parce que
c'est une question de santé publique
le sujet est brûlant voire explosif il
va toucher des millions de Français à
peine installés les aidefe suscitent
colères et inquiétudes
les ZFE ce sont les zones à faible
émission de mobilité
petit à petit les véhicules les plus
polluants ne pourront plus y circuler
[Musique]
l'objectif réduire les émissions de
polluants et améliorer la qualité de
l'air chaque année la pollution
atmosphérique du 48 000 Français
11 métropoles ont déjà mis en place une
ZFE et toutes les agglomérations de plus
de 150 000 habitants vont devoir le
faire d'ici 2025
les habitants de Mézières à 55 km de
Paris dans la circonscription du député
doivent déjà composer avec la ZF
parisienne
ici beaucoup s'y rendre tous les jours
en voiture
Bruno millienne compte sur la pédagogie
pour la faire accepter
dans ces zones périphériques le sujet
est sensible c'est une centaine de
kilomètres tous les jours entre ici
là-bas les déplacements clientèle
je vais de l'autre côté de Paris enfin
bon voilà je suis pleinement concernée
on en arrive même à faire du covoiturage
dans du coup c'est moi qui rapatrie tout
le monde je les prends tous ici et on va
ensemble travailler aujourd'hui si tu
dois changer de véhicule tu passerais à
l'électrique ou à l'hybride électrique
hors de question pourquoi je suis
parfois amené à faire des antennes de
kilomètres
et sincèrement je me vois pas
l'électrique pure je m'y vois pas
habituellement en appartement déjà j'ai
pas de prise donc tout ce qui est
électrique c'est impossible et avec nos
revenus malheureusement on peut pas se
permettre d'aller vers des véhicules
neufs du jour nous pourrez plus rentrer
dans la ZFM vous ferez quoi
malheureusement on va on aura pas le
choix comme tout le monde de trouver
notre alternative mais si j'ai pas le
choix bah soit je démissionnerai soit
transport en commun mes amis c'est la
même chose on en parle parce en fait ils
disent on va peut-être devoir quitter
démissionner parce qu'on pourra pas
faire autrement quand on a fait cette
mission on a bien on a bien eu
conscience de tous les freins qu'il y a
et de l'explosion sociale que ça pouvait
être maintenant le boulot qu'on a fait
c'est d'arriver à trouver à tout le
monde une alternative à la voiture au
niveau des transports c'est compliqué
moi par exemple j'ai pas de bus pas de
train je suis obligé de faire au moins
une demi-heure de voiture pour accéder
au train une heure et demie à 2h de
train
en voiture pour aller chez moi j'ai 80
km je mets une heure en ayant les
bouchons je comprends bien là pour le
coup les transports en commun c'est pas
la solution on sait qu'on a un vrai
problème de transport en commun si
demain on a des locations à des tarifs
relativement à la fois sur le
l'électrique électrique c'est pas la
solution j'ai bien entendu mais au moins
sur l'hybride est-ce que ça c'est des
solutions que vous pourriez prendre
oui on pourrait réfléchir tout le monde
est conscient que le reste à charge est
encore trop important et tout ça c'est à
l'étude au ministère et je pense que ça
va se faire assez rapidement de manière
à gérer le mouvement
à Paris les vignettes critères 4 et 5
sont déjà interdites en 2030 seuls les
critères 1 et les véhicules électriques
pourront circuler
il faut donc développer les alternatives
au tout voiture
ici la solution c'est le train et le
futur RER mais pour cela encore faut-il
adapter la gare
ça sera essentiel à partir du moment où
la ZF à Paris sera contrôlée et que les
gens auront du mal à avoir comment ils
peuvent comment ils peuvent circuler
comment ils peuvent se rendre à Paris
sans sans prendre leur voiture pour ceux
qui continuent à apprendre donc là
effectivement c'est un enjeu important
l'échéance c'est 2024 quand les
premières contraventions vont tomber le
député veut faire de cette garde épones
Mézières un modèle un pôle multimodal
qui regroupe tous les modes de transport
l'idée c'est que les automobilistes
laissent ici leur voiture pour prendre
le train
le RER ou le bus express pour Paris
les élus ont un ambitieux projet
à peu près sur cet endroit là tu vas
avoir un bâtiment où il y aura du
logement et le la brasserie sera au
rez-de-chaussée et tout le parking que
tu as là-bas ça a réservé au pôle des
changements avec un parking silo de 650
places d'accord c'est un parking à
hauteur à étage à étage qui va faire à
peu près je crois qu'il va faire quatre
étages
gratuits alors il sera comme il est
conventionné de France mobilité il sera
gratuit pour tous ceux qui ont pas
naviguer
reste une interrogation les transports
en commun seront-ils suffisants pour
tous ces nouveaux voyageurs
alors les chiffres que
Île-de-France mobilité et holons d'après
eux ça sera suffisamment dimensionné
après
faut se méfier d'Île-de-France mobilité
maire de Mézières sur scène et chacun a
ses responsabilités comment
vous la voyez
alors pour l'habitant je l'apprends mal
maintenant on dit les amis prenez de
l'essence ville critères une et puis
prenez l'électrique ou de l'hybride et
ainsi de suite pour l'habitant pour
l'administrer et on voit aujourd'hui
c'est encore plus compliqué un euro
c'est un euro et je pense qu'il va
falloir qu'on accompagne en tout cas
l'État accompagne réellement accompagne
déjà mon ami oui mais encore plus oui
non franchement c'est compliqué pour la
pour l'habitant on peut arriver à
trouver une alternative à chaque citoyen
même s'ils y croient pas aujourd'hui
quand on leur dit je te promets que ça
existe
le député en est persuadé
reste à convaincre les automobilistes
l'autre mission que ces données le
député c'est d'accompagner les élus
Bruno millienne a entamé un tour de
France pour les guider dans la mise en
place des EDF
ce jour-là escale au Bouscat dans
l'agglomération de Bordeaux les élus
veulent des conseils pour leur futur ZFE
qui doit voir le jour d'ici 2025
[Musique]
le député les incite à la concertation
ce qui est arrivé c'est le fait que ça
partait dans tous les sens que chacun
faisait comme il voulait sur son
territoire sans tenir compte des
territoires à côté que ce soit les
territoires limitrophes à la ZFE or vous
le savez aussi bien que moi le problème
est pas de temps à l'intérieur des édefe
parce qu'en général vous avez des
mobilités alternatives c'est plus pour
les gens qui sont à l'extérieur donc au
niveau acceptation sociale et puis aussi
au niveau acceptation économique pour
tout ce qui est commerçants artisans etc
ceux qui viennent faire des marchés à
l'intérieur des feux pour me prendre que
faut pas leur dire on va vous aider à
changer de véhicule c'est on vous offre
une alternative qui n'est pas forcément
un véhicule il faut qu'on repense
l'usage de la voiture pour un certain
nombre de gens ça va être un changement
de vie quoi même le reste à charge de 3
ou 4000 euros pour certaines familles
c'est inabordable ça se programme sur
plusieurs années c'est des choix de
famille qui sont faits pour pouvoir
acheter à ça ou changer de mode de
déplacement l'aspect subjectif va être
extrêmement importante
le risque de colère voire d'explosion
sociale est dans tous les esprits
il y a les particuliers mais il y a
aussi les commerçants et les artisans
qui seront directement touchés pour eux
aussi l'impact financier n'est pas
négligeable
à Bordeaux un Marc et Camille tiennent
une boutique de saumon fumé et il ne
voit pas comment ils pourront changer
d'utilitaire quand la ZF va se mettre en
place
et donc bonjour
on va pas tout manger
alors un train
en plus vous êtes dedans
et aujourd'hui on va être obligé de
changer de véhicule parce que votre
véhicule est assez ancien voilà on va
faire effectivement des aides pour le
remplacement des véhicules utilitaires
léger c'est le cas ça existe déjà on va
le faire plus donc il y aura des
solutions de subvention effectivement
pour changer de véhicule comme pour les
véhicules des particuliers les mala
conversion sur un véhicule c'est 7000
euros quand même c'est pas rien la
particularité vous pouvez le faire sur
un véhicule d'occasion prime à la
conversion sur un risque vous avez le
bonus écologique plus la prime si si
vous en avez je vous jure aujourd'hui
notre véhicule ce n'est pas dans leur
budget surtout vu la conjoncture alors
le député leur propose une autre
solution il y a d'autres alternatives
que de passer à l'électrique il y a le
rétrofitage où effectivement passer
électrique qui vous coûtera moins cher
que d'en prendre un neuf et puis il y a
aussi le rétrovitage qui peut
au gaz c'est ça
bah oui mais il est bien encore celui-là
en changeant seulement le moteur
il faut arriver à faire c'est que les
aides que vous obteniez pour passer
éventuellement à l'électrique bon ou à
autre chose en tout cas moi il faut pas
que ça vous coûte plus cher que si vous
échangez votre véhicule contre un
véhicule identique au diesel ce qui est
un peu infatra c'est toutes les aides
possibles qui ne sont pas regroupées sur
un site on a demandé quand même qu'il y
a un guichet unique qui répertorie du
coup collectivité par collectivité à la
fois les aides de l'État qui sont
communes à l'ensemble de la France mais
très bien les rappeler quand même et les
aides possibles sur le des collectivités
pour que chacun sache exactement à quoi
il a le droit
un constructeur automobile a déjà
identifié ce marché du rétrofit
à Flins dans sa circonscription Bruno
milliennes vient justement découvrir le
projet du groupe Renault avec une
start-up il lance le rétrofit des
véhicules utilitaires
pourquoi parce que le véhicule
utilitaire d'abord c'est essentiellement
du diesel donc ils veulent confronter
très vite à des changements du fait de
la mise en place notamment des ave fe on
a aussi cette particularité c'est que le
véhicule il est utilisé au quotidien
pour l'activité de professionnels s'ils
ont pu leur véhicule c'est difficile
pour eux de continuer et puis c'est
aussi des véhicules qui sont plus chers
à l'achat et qui seront généralement
équipés typiquement spécifique et donc
du coup le rétrophie a du sens pour sur
ce rétrophyte en moteur électrique dans
un premier temps vous tapez dans le
mille donc voilà c'est parfait on n'a
pas encore fixé définitivement le prix
du rétrophique du kit en lui-même mais
on sait qu'il pourrait être redescendu
par une aide nationale
le premier utilitaire est profité
sortira en janvier 2024
le constructeur a décidé d'investir dans
les nouvelles mobilités
qui accompagnent le déploiement des ETFE
et c'est vrai que la logique c'est que
des feux soit piloté par les territoires
et nous en tant qu'industriel on a
besoin en fait on aurait besoin je sais
pas d'une carte quelque chose de lisible
facile compris pour notre réseau savoir
quels sont les aides dont tel territoire
quels sont les interdictions à laquelle
voilà et donc ça c'est quelque chose sur
lequel on est évidemment un peu en
attente pour pouvoir accompagner
vraiment ce mouvement là de déploiement
de zfendue cette demande ce besoin des
entreprises non non j'avais pas entendu
donc c'est bien c'est pas identifié une
pierre de plus à l'édifice
Bruno Milliane va poursuivre son tour de
France à l'écoute des besoins à la
recherche de nouvelles idées mais il va
surtout devoir faire preuve de pédagogie
et informé sur les solutions
alternatives en 2030 80% des voitures
qui circulent aujourd'hui ne pourront
plus rentrer dans les aides